أتحدث إليكم اليوم
بمشاعر حزن عميق
طوال حياتها جلالة
الملكة
والدتي الحبيبة
كانت مصدر إلهام
لي ولجميع أفراد
عائلتي ونحن مدينون لها بأهم دين
يمكن أن تدين به أي أسرة لأمهم
مقابل حبها.
فهم توجيه المودة ومثال
الملكة إليزابيث كانت حياة
عايشها وعد مع مصيرها
وهي حزينة للغاية في وفاتها
هذا الوعد بالخدمة مدى الحياة الذي
أجدده لكم جميعًا اليوم
جنبًا إلى جنب مع الحزن الشخصي الذي
يشعر به جميع أفراد عائلتي
الذي نشاركه أيضًا  مع الكثير منكم في
المملكة المتحدة
في جميع البلدان التي كانت فيها الملكة على
رأس دولة
في الكومنولث
وفي جميع أنحاء العالم ،
كان شعورًا عميقًا بالامتنان
لأكثر من سبعين عامًا كانت
فيها والدتي
كملكة
خدمت الناس في العديد من الدول.  الأمم
في عام 1947
في عيد ميلادها الحادي والعشرين
، تعهدت في بث من كيب
تاون
إلى الكومنولث
بتكريس حياتها
سواء كانت قصيرة أو
طويلة للخدمة  من بين
شعوبها كان أكثر من مجرد وعد ،
لقد كان التزامًا شخصيًا عميقًا
حدد حياتها كلها ،
فقد قدمت تضحيات من أجل الواجب
، ولم يتزعزع تفانيها وتفانيها في السيادة
في أوقات التغيير والتقدم
خلال أوقات الفرح
والاحتفال وعبر أوقات  لقد رأينا الحزن والخسارة
في حياتها في الخدمة
أن الحب الراسخ للتقاليد
جنبًا إلى جنب مع ذلك الاحتضان الجريء
للتقدم
الذي يجعلنا عظماء كأمم ،
أصبح
الإعجاب والاحترام الذي ألهمته
هو السمة المميزة
لعهدها وكما يمكن لكل فرد من أفراد عائلتي أن
يشهد
لقد جمعت هذه الصفات مع
روح
الدعابة الدافئة والقدرة التي لا تخطئ دائمًا لرؤية
الأفضل في الناس ،
وأشيد بذكرى والدتي
وأكرم حياتها في الخدمة ،
وأعلم أن موتها يجلب
حزنًا كبيرًا لكثير
منكم وأنا أشارك هذا الشعور  من خسارة لا
تُقاس معكم جميعًا
عندما جاءت الملكة إلى عرش
بريطانيا
وكان العالم لا يزال يتعامل مع
الحرمان
وبعد الحرب العالمية الثانية
وما زلنا نعيش وفقًا لاتفاقيات
الأزمنة السابقة
على مدار السبعين عامًا الماضية
، رأينا مجتمعنا أصبح
واحدًا من العديد من الثقافات والعديد من الأديان
تغيرت مؤسسات الدولة
بدورها
ولكن من
خلال جميع التغييرات  وتتحدى
أمتنا
والعائلة الأوسع من
العوالم التي
أنا فخور للغاية بتقاليد مواهبها وإنجازاتها
التي ازدهرت وازدهرت
قيمنا
، ويجب أن تظل
ثابتة ، كما
أن
دور وواجبات الملكية تظل كذلك
كما هو الحال
بالنسبة للعلاقة الخاصة للملك
ومسؤوليته  تجاه كنيسة
إنجلترا ، الكنيسة
التي يتجذر فيها إيماني بعمق
في هذا الإيمان والقيم التي تلهمها ،
لقد نشأت لأحترم
الإحساس بالواجب تجاه الآخرين
ولأحترم التقاليد الثمينة
الحريات والمسؤوليات
لتاريخنا الفريد
ونظامنا للحكومة البرلمانية
كما فعلت الملكة نفسها  مثل هذا
التفاني الذي لا يتزعزع ،
وأنا أيضًا أتعهد الآن رسميًا
طوال الوقت المتبقي ، يمنحني
الله دعم المبادئ الدستورية
في قلب أمتنا
وفي أي مكان قد تعيش فيه في المملكة المتحدة
أو في العوالم والأقاليم في
جميع أنحاء
العالم وأيًا كان  الخلفية أو
المعتقدات سأسعى لخدمتك باحترام
ولاء
وحب
كما فعلت طوال
حياتي بالطبع ستتغير حياتي بالطبع
عندما أتحمل مسؤولياتي الجديدة
، لن يكون من الممكن بالنسبة لي أن
أعطي الكثير من
وقتي وطاقاتي  للجمعيات الخيرية
والقضايا التي أهتم بها بشدة
ولكني أعلم أن هذا العمل المهم سيستمر
في أيدي موثوقة للآخرين ،
وهذا أيضًا وقت تغيير لعائلتي ،
فأنا أعتمد
على المساعدة المحبة من زوجتي المحبوبة
كاميلا
تقديراً لها.  خدمتها العامة المخلصة
منذ زواجنا قبل 17 عامًا
، أصبحت تستشير الملكة
وأنا أعلم أنها ستجلب مطالب
دورها الجديد
الإخلاص الراسخ لدو
التي جئت لأعتمد عليها بقدر
ما يفترض وريث
ويليام
الآن الألقاب الاسكتلندية التي
كانت تعني الكثير بالنسبة لي ،
فهو يخلفني دوق كورنوال
ويتحمل مسؤوليات
الدرع الهولندي كورنوال الذي توليته
لأكثر من  خمسة عقود
اليوم
أنا فخور بتكوينه أمير ويلز
لإبلاغ
كامري البلد
الذي كان لي شرف كبير لتحمل لقبه
خلال الكثير من حياتي والواجب
مع كاثرين بجانبه ،
فإن أميرنا الجديد وأميرة ويلز
سوف أعرف
الاستمرار في إلهام وقيادة
محادثاتنا الوطنية التي
تساعد على جلب الهامش إلى
وسط الأرض
حيث يمكن تقديم المساعدة الحيوية ،
وأريد أيضًا أن أعبر عن
حبي لهاري وميغان
وهم يواصلون بناء حياتهم
في الخارج في فترة تزيد قليلاً عن أسبوع
نحن  سوف يجتمعون كأمة
كدولة كومنولث وفي الواقع مجتمع عالمي
لأضع والدتي الحبيبة للراحة
في حزننا ، دعونا
نتذكر ونستمد القوة من نور زوجها
السابق
نيابة عن جميع أفراد عائلتي ،
لا يسعني إلا أن
أقدم خالص الشكر والصادق
على تعازيك ودعمك
الذي يعنيه لي أكثر مما يمكنني
التعبير عنه
ولأمي العزيزة
عندما تبدأ رحلتك الرائعة الأخيرة
للانضمام إلى عزيزي في وقت متأخر  أبي ،
أريد ببساطة أن أقول هذا ،
شكرًا لك
على
حبك وتفانيك لعائلتنا
ولعائلة الأمم التي
خدمتها بجد طوال هذه السنوات ،
قد
تغني لك رحلات الملائكة لراحتك